olá votaram e hoje sim tomar sobre
eletrônica em material pouco
convencional
eu enquanto estudante eletrônica e
telecomunicações
porém com alguns problemas no que toca a
prototipagem de circuitos eletrônicos
quando eu comecei a fazer os projetos é
esta as plaquinhas verdes a quais os
oceanos a eletrônica e para eu descobrir
que elas eram muito caras
é o processo é muito lento mesmo
processo de encomenda nas empresas era
complicado principalmente por pessoas e
amazonas
por isso eu tentei criar algo que
entendemos lembrar de algo que pudesse
resolver este problema e poderá imprimir
circuitos uma forma fácil rápida e
barata e foi campeã em uma impressora
velha que tinha em casa e ao 3d maneira
ela podia funcionar com com tinta você
ali na partículas material condutor de
la silla
pouco tempo depois fez o arranjo sistema
e já tinha um sistema em que eu
basicamente uma superfície comercial
comprar uma impressora jato de tinta não
tinha os meus 37 e ela estava pronta a
funcionar e pronta imprimiram
literalmente eletrônica em papel e
outros tipos de materiais como funciona
também é eu comecei a ver muito sangue
pode ser uma ponte muito importante para
qualquer pessoa em casa podia ter acesso
à tecnologia e à parte o protótipo paz
em que só algumas pessoas é que tenham
acesso a um vídeo que eu vou mostrar a
seguir é um algumas coisas engraçadas
pode fazer com o mesmo
depois disto é cada vez que meu irmão
minha reclamar a dizer que a minha mãe
porque achei que tinha tirado comando
jogos já consegue dizer pelo primeiro
nós podemos ver aqui que de alguma
maneira e isto é sempre e é esta parte
da impressão pode ser uma ferramenta
muito barata e muito simples para
estimular as crianças para agosto
eletrônica hoje em dia vivemos rodeados
tecnologia e em portanto dizer se elas
começam a ganhar alguma sensível levado
para a parte tecnológica
comecei a pensar em soluções pudessem
aumentar esta é esta em 3 pelas crianças
e este vídeo vai mostrar uma das idéias
basicamente temos aqui uma com uma
caneta em um papel e com os pequenos
circuitos em stick coca cola com e fita
cola com torneio touchdown
nós podemos fazer alguns circuitos
vizinhos e engraçados
ou seja a partir do meio deste momento
nós com uma pequena folha de papel e uma
caneta e componentes eletrônicos simples
qualquer criança pode facilmente começar
a criar eletrônica de uma maneira
engraçada e didática em sala mas agora
se pensarmos em ao pouso do dia a dia
desta tecnologia
eu enquanto estudantes e eu sempre
trabalhei ea e por ter trabalhado foi a
foi determinante na escolha do tema da
minha tese foi o que escolhi como efe
essa é quando eu comecei certa forma há
a a primeira vez que esse era o meu
retorno
quando saí é trabalhar trabalhar na tese
eu achava que eu trabalhei numa empresa
da talha eu achava que a tecnologia é
file podia de certa forma a resolver
alguns problemas que auxiliam na gestão
de estoques
por isso eu queria imprimir ué esta
gente que tá se referiu indiretamente
nos produtos
a tecnologia é falling consiste numa
tecnologia e ao contrário do código de
barras em que é preciso contato visual
com uma etiqueta é de referir que
consiste num sistema em que a existe uma
antena que me tu andas ravi e essas
ondas do rádio entrarem quando encontrou
essas etiquetas elas respondem com uma
informação ou a uma identificação a qual
lan a qual não é preciso pilha e
socializa a a vários metros de distância
uma utilização pode ser feito visto joão
um supermercado em cheio o vosso
carrinho de compras e no momento em que
é pra pagar vocês passam uma espécie de
escutas com a como antenas e eu faço do
teto tem no carrinho e faixa quanto
automaticamente uma questão segundos
isso é uma das organizações mais a nível
industrial muitas outras utilizações
utilizações podem ser pode ser usada
tecnologia o seu ego e por isso poderá
imprimir em vários tipos de material
nós podemos criar a antenas por exemplo
patronos podemos até substituir os
carros nos carros eléctrico pode começar
a imprimir directamente o as linhas
condutoras na estrutura do carro
isso pode ser um dizendo assim eu já
falei de carros de educação a escola não
é crianças e agora falta uma coisa que é
casas não é esta pureza aqui está a
mostrar por exemplo uma qualquer cá o
uma parede que vocês tenham em casa e
espero que não seja tão torta como esta
nem tomar pintá la mas eu se lhe pagar é
pago nesta tecnologia e de alguma
maneira vou tentar é usá-la em casa e
isso é uma das utilizações pode ser
feito para tentar contornar por trás
desta tinta e imagino que vocês podem
programar ações de engraçada sem cintos
em vossa casa por exemplo eu comecei um
grande preguiçoso esteve lá uma coisa
que eu sempre queria era a acender e
apagar a luz sem ter como levantados fã
deputado era ser muito chato
então é às vezes ficava com os
sacrifícios a que algo diferente é só
por causa da preguiça e isso é algo que
fosse deste ano
nós nós fato de essas ligar ou desligar
a luz ou aumentar e diminuir
de certa forma a intensidade da luz
frisando ser uma dos casos
agora imagina que você estava a ler e
criam em qualquer jogo na nossa casa uma
luz direcional seria se calhar engraçado
nós com tinta magnética aliada tenta com
toda e os leds com gimenez na conta
podemos fazer coisas deixando até ligar
a luz em qualquer sítio da casa ou do
aparelho ou se nós quiséssemos criar uma
luz ambiente
por exemplo pensava ok e agora e se nós
quiséssemos controlar músicas em casa o
próprio fazer um piano em casa
o acumulado instrumentos
quem não gostar do piano
ou querem a mãe disso
sobre o jogo
julie julia julia graças à utilização
jung sung ryong jung onde está sob joão
leão
julie julia